hi there this is steve again uh this is
the second video on how to learn chinese
using link
in the first video i
explained how you could where you could
find content
in the second one i'm going to talk to
you talk to you about how we use the
content
um
i've got i'm looking here at my lessons
page
uh this is under lessons you know we
have lessons friends which i'll talk
about in another video forum and so
forth
and here we have under lessons we have
the library my lessons vocabulary
write where you can have your writing
corrected speak you can import you can
find your tutors
but here's where we look at the lessons
now
i used the
bookmarklet to import two articles which
we can we'll look at one of them
but first let's start with uh let's say
you're a beginner well i think a good
place to start is this simple story
called who is she which is in 26
episodes
and it starts very easily and it's
available all 26 episodes episodes have
a translation into english or into
whatever is your any of the other 11
languages that we support
it has pinyin to help you out
and of course you can
listen to it
all right
so
in this lesson i have no blue words no
unknown words to me bear in mind that i
don't normally study chinese at link
a beginner would see a lot of words in
blue
you of course can look at these yellow
words which are words that you have
previously looked up you can
you can hear them
uh if you think you know them you can
advance their status
uh to two and so on and so on
uh and that's i guess enough here to
look at one thing i should point out
that you can always check out the
tutorial view
which
goes through step by step where the
audio player is located
uh you know then this is the number of
new words in the lesson which is zero in
this case for me
uh
it tells you that uh you need to you
know click linked after you finish
creating the links well you have zero
here but otherwise if there were five
new words that you had passed over then
you click on linked i'll show this in
another lesson
in order to add these to your known
words total and anyway that's enough
with that
now let us go
to
the
we will open the actually we can go back
to the my lessons view
and uh and we'll go to the next one
which is let's say part 10 in this
episode there's 25 26 episodes and all
here we see some blue words all right
these are words that i have not yet come
across
you can also hear it
okay boyfriend if you want that and
these are three different
um meanings that our members have
selected from different dictionaries
that they use you of course can
uh you can choose to take one of these
or you can search your dictionary
and now you should set a dictionary as
your default okay this is rather
important
so we had it set for google search but
you might prefer to use a word reference
so you can set up any dictionary that
you want as your default dictionary and
but it's going to give you the same
meaning as
as we already have
and this can be copied in
like so
i'm you're not able to see my other
screen but so you could do that but
that's what we basically we had the
english there okay
uh what else is there you
may choose rather than reading through
the whole text if you wanted to go
through
and quickly link the blue words you can
press on the
uh quick link view and then
you can quickly go through okay
okay and so you are to
so you can add these pandora you can add
these
very very quickly so you can quickly
come up with all these linked words and
then you can go back to the standard
view
and at that point you might want to save
a phrase
like that you know
live together you might want to listen
to it
and you might want to save that so at
that point you might find it interesting
to save some phrases
you might also go back and find some of
the words that you have saved
like uh to run and you might want to
um
create a tag for it now i have
previously tagged this as an adverb
but i might want to tag something as
important
or flag
and all these tags do is that they
create lists for you when you go to the
vocabulary section so that you can
review a whole bunch of adverbs or words
that you consider to be important or any
other way in which you choose to tag
them all right now let's go back to the
my lessons page
and we'll have a look at one of the
items
that i brought in this is from our
canadian
chinese language forum
and it talks about uh tax evasion
amongst chinese immigrants here
so uh
chinese this is jungwon wang and so you
can
well
you see you can always improve
and uh you can save that if you want now
here again you can take the quick link
view but you would have a lot of blue
words if there are this many blue words
i prefer to go through
uh reading text
and so you can
and
you know lee from or separated from
and it's just to show you that that
obviously the more difficult the text
the denser the blue words are going to
be one other thing you've got english in
here you may not want the english to
appear because you could be adding that
to
your known words total
so you go there's a pencil which allows
you to go down there and wherever you
see any english
you just
delete the english
uh five year tax holiday but that's up
to you
personally i'm not such a stickler if my
known words total is out by a couple of
hundred it's not a big deal while you're
in this edit
mode you can see that you have the
ability to add
lesson notes translations videos pinion
exercises other attachments that's
mostly for
someone who is providing a lesson for
our community they can also add an audio
file here
but if you're doing this for your own
purposes
such as is the case with uh with this
particular item then you don't need to
bother
okay and so now we've removed the oh i
didn't get that one but we removed some
of the other english
and so there you go
basically that's the main thing is you
want to be linking
again you can go to the tutorial uh view
and it'll give you advice
uh it it skips the first one because
there is no sound bar because we didn't
import sound with this we only imported
the text so
you know it's it's impossible to go
through all of the different things that
i do in link but hopefully that
generates some interest and if you have
any questions please don't